les familles ont de l'eau plus occupé
que les autres semaines qu'on le prend
le plus c'est les chutes en quart de
coupe des branches conjugales on ne
pensait d à peine 2
convenu avec le moteur avec les facultés
affaiblies
demandez à peine de m'échapper de vol
fois que c'est réglé dans le sang et or
pour le place mondiale ce coup ci c'est
tout les mêmes personnes qui commettent
les infractions a pris l'habitude
d'aller dans ses passions
on fait beaucoup de travail social on
discute avec les jeunes lors des
international
on fait souvent avec des gens qui sont
intoxiqués alors on doit on a mesuré
notre niveau là de social a vécu on
avait fait ses amis pour éviter qu'ils
dérangent mais voilà sa famille
depuis neuf ans je suis ici c'est mon
premier poste ferait rater deux
policiers c'est vraiment bien c'est la
nature
les débuts des corps de beaux paysages
les gens sympathiques m'ont annoncé jean
baptiste awashish ses patrouilles à sa
fin les amis que j'ai réussi pour la
oumma la communauté de vie je le fais
pour beaucoup la cma communauté si ce
que sétif s'est déterminé dans le
plaisir ma maison après ça le foot des
suisses et puis a terminé
c'est des gens que je côtoie souvent par
la ville en 2007 amélioration du poteau
police sont construction de 2006 qui ont
inauguré le poste il ya des professeurs
sont venus mais j'en oublie juste est
très familial très conviviale que c'est
vraiment pas au mondial c'est le monde
est proche
les liens sont tissés c'est mon sens
trahi de la communauté et professeurs
les policiers
tout le monde se connaître c'est
vraiment un beau matin de type c'est
vraiment bien de sa famille
elle seulement les fins de mois c'est
assez mouvementée aider chaque lien
social après l'échec
concernant le secret le conseil ça sonne
pas de rappeler d'argent en même temps
absolument les fins de semaine il a
offert 3 kills est pauvre ou plutôt le
coup choses afin d'alléger la motion
rompuy il faut en effet donné raison
oui ce site qui est très commune si les
traditionnels
est-ce que c'est difficile d'intervenir
quand c'est votre famille c'est ce que
c'est difficile je dois gérer attaque
policiers même si massa au mont pas j'ai
déjà intervenus souvent mes frères
bompas fallait âgées attaque police y
est arrivé c'était quelque chose puis
année après année ça s'améliore mais
c'est sûr que quelqu'un qui restera
comme moi qui vois des choses comme ça
c'est assez impressionnant
on y une communauté très éloignés des
gens les achètent de havas de monter et
achètent beaucoup de qualités de
boissons méconnaît autochtone c'est
l'argent que leur cousin hongrie cette
fois ci c'est souvent pour que soient
pas trop à l'intérieur de ce genre de
situation alors c'est pour ça que nous
les positionnements autochtone on
apporte un certain appui halle pour
cette année comme d'autres on reconnaît
pour les on en connaît le monde donc on
n'est pas la famille aux taxes et
personne n'est pas aussi proche
alors je vous présente le bloc
cellulaire dans le cas de céline est ce
que très occupé il est habituellement
oui mais les fins de mois absolument vol
de plusieurs personnes qui pensent par
ici mais vous assez plus l'été l'été ça
bouge beaucoup il fait chaud tout le
monde est derrière l'alcool est de mise
les parties sont des gens sont en
vacances aussi
alors tu espères à la faillite
une intervention qui brosse un peu une
centre d'interrogatoire puis ici une
personne qui sait franchi qui avait à
son chef dans la fenêtre pour sauter et
briser sur cette seconde franche et
donne des coups des points comme ça
donne des coups de pied et ça fait
forcer la porte
ça fait forcément le cadrage au tout
qu'est-ce que vous cessez le plus ici
les armes à feu les stupéfiants ménages
a douché cette semaine je suis j'ai
saisi des stupéfiants
les syndics 95.5 pilules de
méthamphétamine sur un individu vivant
ils sont très tranchant l'ibook
chasseurs ici fait que des hommes parce
que moi toutes les maisons et pourquoi
vous les avez saisi ses armes et leurs
exactement ce qu'on intervient dans une
association de violences conjugales
et puis il ya des hommes qui sont
écoutés souvent les enfants entre projet
alors on les amène ici réseau loin
citoyen appel car peu importe d'accord
pour nous redonner dans l'obligation
d'intervenir si ce pôle est certainement
criminelle il faut régler sur place
essayer de régler en famille qui se
posent à maison on gère le tout jusqu'à
la fin alors qu'on va prendre un peu de
violence conjugale on prend les
informations il plaignent des victimes
des témoins on sera sur place on prend
les cartons des témoins déclaration du
plaignant les demandeurs agression on
pensait dans ses rangs du suspect
montceau qui lui suspect
la passion on vient ici pour le détenir
on regrette beaucoup que les personnes
dont le contrat certain soutien moral
c'est du travail social ils font peu le
porte un souci maintenant je le parle
mondiale pour du groupement une forme
d'apartheid éric lapointe quand vous
allez sur une opération là pour répondre
à un appel
est ce qu'il vous arrive parfois d'avoir
peint est ce que je vais revenir vivants
ou souhaite achever appel d'art marc
parent et il y avait beaucoup d'appels
d'armes à feu je me marre c'est pourquoi
la famine et puis ma femme puis me zahaf
est-ce que je m'aventure d'appel d'armes
à feu je vais vous revenir je vous redis
aujourd'hui répond quand j'étais un lui
dans la chambre c'est là que j'ai vu ma
nièce s'est pendu pis ses lucratives
grattez dieu pour moi parce que c'est ma
nièce mafia russe visait parce que j'ai
jamais passé que ça règle sa evra dans
ma famille à moi j'ai toujours garde des
sceaux j'ai jamais on va on ferait
référer à personne de la cij et tours
accumulés pendant des années d'être sans
ces poids et vidal et ramassé ricard
coupé puis des gens que je connaissais
de la répression c'est ce que certains
combos choix mais on essaie d'éviter sur
le plus possible la préparation c'est le
gong
on ne verrait plus de la population et
des gens spécialement